all right
Wesley you came here and you were kind
of incredulous about the eval of the
engine being minus two at the end of the
game how did you assess that position
how did you come up to the conclusion
yeah repetition is the best
well no I just thought things went out
of control I mean it doesn't even make
sense looking at the computer these days
because they're just too strong and the
evaluation
is inhuman so totally unrealistic but uh
well I thought the position was very
complicated at that stage I was also
disappointed that I missed a very good
winning chance against the act the other
day so it wasn't especially hoping for
much today but I thought they got a good
petition and then you were showing me
some lines earlier
like with the exchange sacrifice with
Rook to D5 yeah yeah I thought this
and I mean probably should add more
lines here on the engine so that we know
if Asics is the only way anymore so A6
Queen E1
takes oh I guess
I didn't see Queen G6
or A6 and it's more of a slow burning
Advantage right it doesn't finish in the
next three moves nothing super tactical
yeah yeah I mean
problem is I can't get my Rook so A6
Queen A5 Bishop Queen E1 yeah and I
didn't see Queen G6 this is slow Retreat
and it's minus four
yeah it's just Knight H5 is a big
problem Rook E8 is a big problem right
now
if it goes to G3
let's see
ah which five
ah Queen G6 so yeah I just thought they
missed Queen G6 but even Bishop to D7 it
was a good chance
Bishop D7 was not clear because I was
calculating so many lines after H4 I
guess H4 is a mistake but it's already
not so easy
uh like I was first I was gonna go here
but then I saw Knight D5 Queen G3 King
D2
okay connection is a bit unrealistic
right yeah I mean just that's a funny
move doesn't make sense look at a
computer when you're
when we're playing a human and also how
would you describe this position because
sure we see this evals is like minus
three minus four or four but they're not
easy to calculate and you have options
at every single move your opponent has
options at every single movement no I
thought I had very good I thought its
position was very close to collapsing
for him for him yeah
just couldn't find enough outflow like
here I spent 25 minutes thinking uh
Queen F4 looks very tempting but but
yeah the
I was hoping for Queen E3 and then I
would give a check
like I was calculating fun lines like
this
okay it's just completely winning of
course
but it's
easier
said when you have engine right friendly
but turquoin for Knight D5
but uh yeah I thought a very good chance
today just didn't find The Knockout blow
like uh I was talking 94 but 94 is not
enough for a win
because he goes like this and he just
barely hangs on but that's the thing
even in this position you're still
better right yeah maybe not that's easy
but you're still objectively better yeah
but the problem is we have good choices
and you want to find the one that
that um it's just crashing yeah but yeah
of course I should
EX play this exchange sacrifice I just
think Queen G6 but let's go down to the
last few yeah moments of the game I was
very surprised when you played Rook D1
actually yes yeah
I don't know what's going on
yeah I guess I didn't realize that I'm
guessing p7 was at least according to
the engine not the precise move
yeah I I think he started shaking his
head because after King D1 Rook d8 I
cannot he can play King E1 I guess he
missed
Bishop E7 or Bishop B3
but it's not winning for black
but uh Queen B7 also had little time at
this point
um
were you still still harboring hopes for
for an advantage here or were you ready
to kind of
you know make make a drive
well it wasn't 100 sure who's playing
for a win that's the problem also I was
getting low on time I mean of course if
I have some chance I would push it yeah
but here I was calculating Queen B7 then
I couldn't find how to untangle because
after 98
got E5
yeah this is not easy anymore
yeah because with my knight on E8
I'm not sure also how strong this engine
is because usually
yeah you have to give at least like that
30 that 35 to be accurate
but I didn't realize that this position
is plus two hmm
like I thought he's got a pawn
for a queen and three pieces I guess
three pieces but
yeah just like push the pawns maybe G5
F4 try to to get something on the king
side that's wide right
it does look a little bit dangerous
for for you if you manages to push your
pieces out
yeah I still have no idea what's uh
going on here finally this is plus two
because the bishop an E6 defense
everything
but of course it's now that I see the
evaluation is very stupid for me to
repeat but during the game I wasn't
a hundred percent sure if
who's better or how much better I really
am age
you mentioned that at the beginning that
you were a bit disappointed about the
result again spoke down uh in the
previous round uh this is sure another
misstep objective misstep how are you
going to deal with uh the psychological
blow
well I've been doing this for eight and
a half years so it's just another day in
the office for me I mean obviously I
wanted better I thought ding wasn't in
good shape in this tournament like when
he started making all these bad moves in
the opening like Queen very aggressive
yeah I mean E4 you should just try to
I don't know like I guess he didn't want
to
make a draw so early in the game
so that's why I played E4 but only white
could run into trouble here
um
so well just take it day the time I
still got plenty of tournaments left in
the year in this FSA St Louis just try
to keep getting better uh day by day and
hope that things go your way but I'm
very pleased that my computer at Fabiana
is doing
extremely well in this tournament I
think the last two times between Romania
or the last three times actually didn't
go well but
very glad that he's winning almost every
game here but it's a Pity that I didn't
convert today who had been a big treat
beating the world champion but yeah I
still find it very stupid that I
repeated moves in this position but yeah
without the engine without the engine is
not that easy to to assess this
imbalance positions Wesley yeah actually
interesting if you ask random GMS what
they think
of the assessment this position I I
don't think anyone would give blood for
black and maybe we can throw that
question to uh to the guys in St Louis
Wesley thank you very much yeah thank
you so much for having me
thank you Christian thank you Wesley it
goes to show Nancy what a very